what up is your boy burner man check me
out on the bootleg caf podcast about an
hour worth the game you don't want to
miss it
sure
are we rolling
all right
we are here boo let kev podcast
it's been a long time man i want to say
the last time we did an interview was in
2017.
what's that like four years it's been a
while yeah we've seen each other we talk
a lot you know but as far as like
actually sitting down and having a
conversation it's been a long time man
you did a whole season at bernie's
roundtable yeah i tried i tried i tried
it out man you tried it and it was great
it was good you know it was good i
actually really enjoyed it i just
you know you guys use your time like
as you know best as you can i don't know
if that was well received i'm glad you
liked it i will do it again i love the
tommy chong episode yeah that was good
that was a good one it was good man no
um
you know it's funny because i just was
watching an interview with joe rogan one
of his episodes and he was saying like
the guy on the show was trying to
convince him to do nfts and joe was like
i don't have time for this [ __ ] like all
the time i have like has to be
you know allocated wisely yeah you know
what i mean you gotta pick you gotta
pick your projects i mean people have
been getting at me about nfts every day
and it's like every every day a new
homie figures out what nft is and calls
me with this master plan
it's kind of like the cbd joke like i
got it i got a great idea let's start a
cbd company like everyone everyone has a
cbd company yeah you know so i i don't
know about the nfc [ __ ] i just don't
understand it and i don't want to do
something for my audience that doesn't
make sense if i can make it make sense
for me like up here then i'll do it but
i just don't understand it bro well you
know what i think you do a great job of
that
i don't do a good job of and that's like
you have so much [ __ ] going on so many
companies you got your music but i
always feel like you do a great job of
balancing family
and work
you got to how did you figure like
that's not an easy thing to figure out
how to do like how did you
how do you do that so well well i just
know that like at the end of the day our
kids only know what we teach them and
you know like i just
i really love my kids i love the family
and i just try to that's like actually
the balance i need to keep going because
as spread then as i am bro like i'll
i'll burn out sooner or later so like
it's good to like be able to just turn
the phone off and just focus on family
and people respect it now in my circle
when i'm with the kids or when i'm with
the fam they just know that's the
balance i need to to keep working like
this it's tough to work like this bro
super super draining nah dude especially
like
however you figured out how to keep
everything going while also kind of
being off the map during kobe because
for people who don't know you were kind
of
you was duck ducked off up north
ghosted during covey but yet you were
still making [ __ ] happen like there was
still grand openings happening and you
know of cookie stores all over the
country like we do new music we you know
kept the clothing rocking i think that
the day like kobe was a big test
mentally for people to see like
can you keep it cracking you know i mean
can you keep your sanity can you and
it's tough man like we took the
precautions before we sat down you know
and that's the way i have it now like i
got eight tests in my backpack you know
each test kit got two if i see someone
they gotta take a test i think it is the
best most responsible thing to do
whether it's accurate or not it's a good
piece of mind because we can't treat
people like journalists man it's just
like it's getting weird so for me that's
been the best like now that the tests
are more available at walgreens and
whatnot i've been able to move around a
little more um but yeah kovi was rough
bro and i just bought a house in the
cuts and just chilled out for as long as
i could and
i think that like it really like let
people understand life is precious and
you got to pick your circles you know
what i mean yeah you've been extremely
cautious with with uh with the covet
[ __ ] a lot more cautious than some of
your counterparts maybe in the hip-hop
game right like what what's the
motivation behind that i mean my uncles
died for me two of them and like you
know i look at my text every other day
to remind myself you know he was just
fine like me and you were
and then was like i'm going to hospital
and then from the hospital's like yo
they're going to put me on this machine
and die and so it's like it happens like
that you know what i mean and so
i've seen a lot of people struggle for
it and i think that people that lost
people to covet it hits a little harder
it's home yeah my grandma died man
exactly and so like you know i've just
been bro i'm always been paranoid though
bro that's why you know i'm always
worried that's why i've never been you
know never been to jail i never i've
always moved a certain way and i think
that's what got me where i'm at bro's
just being cautious but at the same time
like i understand you still got to move
you know i mean so just move right yeah
that's real i think uh
it's been a weird like unfortunately
like kovacs i feel like also has
originally i felt like it was politics
that was dividing people
and that kind of leaked into
covid dividing people i believe cover's
a way bigger agenda than what we see it
as right now it's it's a very big agenda
to
in my opinion and we won't dive into it
too deep but i feel like it's a attack
on you know us as as a civilization but
also like us as america too i think
they're trying to [ __ ] our [ __ ]
our economy and just us as people you
have to understand covert is more of a
mental thing than it is anything
it's really like when you get covered
you're by yourself you have to isolate
you have to social it's like just
[ __ ] with your head hella much and
the way i look at it now is like all
right look my kids are back in school
i'll take the risk for that
i mean let them go back to school let
them enjoy their life let them chill
with their friends let them play sports
if i'm gonna get this [ __ ] i'ma get it
from the house but i'll take the
precautions when i'm out and about for
sure got two men let's go back burn like
um
you know for people who don't know where
did you start at when it comes to making
music and getting into the weed game
from the jump yeah and i mean music i've
always been a fan of music and that's
why i still make it i don't make music
because it makes me bright or i don't
think i'm the best musician i'm a fan of
i love to put records together so i
started off musically by battle rapping
and frisco
um at this coffee shop on hay street
let's go there and battle rap cats and
had fun with it and used to battle rap
hell of people and just
i mean i don't even think a lot of
people know that but that's how i
started [ __ ] with it and then from
there um i met some cool producers and
you know i had an a-track at the time i
was making music in my garage in arizona
um i told the story before a couple
times but i was in a continuation school
in arizona a kid approached me and he
was kind of like this where i first
started before going to frisco
um he tried to convince me he's like yo
you look like a rapper you'd probably be
a dope rapper
spit something i'm like spit what like
how do you how do you do it he like spit
a little freestyle got me doing his
whack he's like man i think you should
buy my equipment you should buy my
little eight track or it was a four
track or whatever was it right it was
like not even that actually it was like
a karaoke setup type thing he's like you
can record music you put the beat you
rap on the mic you can make your own
[ __ ] like really so i went ask my mom
for the money she was kind of against it
but gave it to me was like 200 300 bucks
or something i bought it off him and i
remember watching him go back to his
friends that he upgraded to a four track
or eight track so i was like ah
[ __ ] kind of played me but i
started playing with it so
start out just [ __ ] around the garage
in arizona 110 degree [ __ ] garage
serious heat and i told my mom i was
like look if i ever want to take this
music [ __ ] seriously i got to get back
to debate we should move back to the bay
area because where we're from that's
what an independent music game is that's
jt was doing his thing go toes was doing
his thing jives there everyone was there
i just seen like you know e40 i was like
i'm never going to make music here in
arizona i think my mom was supportive i
was like let's go move back to the bay
then [ __ ] it so your mom actually
made the decision to move back to the
bay based on you wanting to pursue music
yeah that's huge that's that's a big
gamble on her part
because she changed everything she
changed like her work path like
everything she was doing she just
switched up for that which is dope as
[ __ ] what year did your mom pass um
2010. so she kind of got to see like the
beginning of this starting to really
work out yeah she started like right
like um she saw up until like um
she saw a weekend at bernie she saw like
[ __ ] like that and i think like
she didn't see the
she didn't see yoko the white album she
didn't see yoga and all that stuff nah
but she at least she saw that there was
like she saw i stopped man
she used to teach workout classes to my
[ __ ] wow
you know water aerobics classes to my
[ __ ] you know my [ __ ] ain't nothing
teach no [ __ ] aerobics right right
right hilarious actually that's that's
funny and then what about like you know
the weed [ __ ] obviously you know
you talk about it in your raps all the
time and and but but
when did you kind of
start to become like serious when it
came to just the weed [ __ ] because
obviously it all starts from a place
where it's trapping
and then it evolves
and i was like i got to do this you know
no matter what it is from
doing what i was doing when i was
younger to
getting into the dispensary stuff to you
know when i was just working at a
dispensary you were doing security
dispensary some right i got hired as
like um
kind of like an intake person like you
know people show up i check their
doctor's letter and make sure it's
official call the doctor check buzz them
into the the main area where they go by
the weed and then move me into like we
actually like sell the wheat i was a bud
tender and then went from there to a
buyer and that's when i really fell in
love with the [ __ ] talking to all the
vendors and the growers and seeing
different strains and whatnot then to a
manager running the shop and
it's funny because people would come in
fans of the music and couldn't believe i
just worked there they thought i owned
it
and so so people would be [ __ ] with
your music come to the dispensary and
then they see you and they'd be like oh
this is a burner spot but you were just
that was my shop i just was [ __ ]
working there because i loved it and as
my music career got bigger and bigger i
had to commit less and less time to work
in there and eventually just figured out
how to do my own thing you know
so
yeah cause like with cookies like i
remember like i remember like the first
time i
me and you met was it was in 2013
at south by but before that
it might we might have met before that
in phoenix i don't know if that was
before after you and chevy did that
little tour run um button says to us
yeah but i remember there was like a
world star video of you and some like
asian chick yeah where you would having
to do interesting things with smoke a
lot of people a lot of people don't know
why i did that like i'm not proud of
that [ __ ] and i always joke about that
she's gonna come back and haunt me shout
out to sugi
um and there was one before her too
but like
so we're the first ones ever put a hash
pen in front of the world like no one's
ever seen what everyone uses now the
vape ends i was the first we're the
first crew to ever show that off like my
my guys invented that [ __ ] right
it was before anyone's seen it and um i
was trying to figure out a way to get
equity in the company i'm like yo this
shit's about to be a game this is
[ __ ] 20 90 should be able to hit a
[ __ ] hash independent what the [ __ ]
yeah and so um
they didn't really understand the reach
i had and i knew the internet and
promotion or whatever and it's a world
star era too then so this is when world
star was cracking and so they're like
look if you can get us an amazing around
amount of promotion
you know we we consider bringing you as
a partner i'm like all right so i just
thought stoner girl's gone wild and i
just did it and it hit like millions of
views the same day and i was like is
this good enough and they were so
[ __ ] mad they're like dude what the
[ __ ] would you do that for but everyone
wanted the pen after that
so you know
they're like well you did that once you
can't pull it off again i'm like [ __ ]
i already got an idea and i met sookie
in the strip club and
i was like you want to be famous and she
was like how i'm like
[ __ ] it'd probably be better if i just
holler at you outside of here and yeah
and i was like look you're gonna smoke
this pan with your ass and she's like
you're [ __ ] nuts i was like i bet you
goes viral and i bet you [ __ ] goes crazy
and she's like
we were i never forget we're at lunch
and uh she has to wait so it's like man
man
if i smoke this pen with my ass on
camera does that make me a horse like a
[ __ ] no but it's pretty [ __ ] weird
it's like weird i could deal with it
so you know [ __ ] shout out to suki that
[ __ ] went platinum drake dm me because
of that wow drake shot me a dm like oh
you're a wild man you know pull up to me
at the motto video i'm in the bay i'm
like damn that full scene that [ __ ] so
it is what it is man that [ __ ] did what
it did you know yo like
the backstory behind cookies because
cookies has become
i mean weed aside
i feel like it's the best seller at
zoomies it's gotta be i mean every time
i go to zoomies this i mean
front of the window all over the country
the the clothing line itself has just
became its own monster man like
it's it's dope as [ __ ] because i never
thought it would last this long you see
clothing lines kind of like rise and dip
yeah always we ain't dip bro we're still
going i think there's so much more
growth and i think the reason why it's
popping is because clothes are dope the
accessories are dope it's innovative
it's it's fly it looks clean it's not
too much like
and like i did it the right way like i
never like i watched clothing companies
back in the days to send huge boxes to
people and i never did that bro i never
i had too much pride as an artist as
well to beg other artists to promote my
[ __ ] i just let that [ __ ] right off my
fan base and my fan base and my
supporters started blowing that [ __ ] up
and i still don't know how that [ __ ] is
yeah it used to be like i'd go to the
airport and if i saw someone with some
cookie [ __ ] on i'd be like oh do you
know like do you know burn or like you
know like
because it was a very small like niche
type of community but now everyone has
cookies you know what side to me
cookie's out groomy people know who
cookie what cookies is and don't know me
and that's amazing because before it was
the other way around yeah yeah before
they'd be like oh yeah bernie but
people see people with cookies on like
you know burn like who
this is amazing it worked what is like
like
give people like an idea of i've heard i
mean i heard some numbers a couple of
years ago like about how how good y'all
were doing on the clothing side
but like give me an idea on how good
this thing is is doing right now only
because i love you i always if you look
at any interview i always say i'm not
talking numbers but you know at some
point in time like you know i see all
the rappers online flexing with their
you know their cast by their ear and
[ __ ] i don't do that [ __ ] but
i mean i guess i'll flex today i mean
cookies on pat like probably like um
i think 50 55 million this year clothing
just clothing just clothing yeah last
other countries yet like we haven't
really done what we're about to do you
know there's the future forecast of
cookies clothing just the clothing not
the weed just the clothing is pretty
dope yeah and i think too like just some
of the like
collabs and like the licensing like when
you guys do like the scarface line or
the the goodfellas line that just came
out sick like it's always on point and
some of the next ones we have coming are
going to shock the [ __ ] out of people
like some of the ones that we've locked
down is incredible like i can't believe
we got it wow yeah um okay and then on
the because you know i do feel like you
don't get it
for whatever reason you don't get enough
respect on a lot of fronts yeah i don't
know i like that [ __ ] as a rapper yeah
you're i think you're the hardest
working rap i mean i don't know people
who have output like you there's very
few people maybe the griselda guys who
are putting out as much albums as you do
every year 40 plus albums out right now
i feel like it's three or four a year
automatic and i own the catalog
so it's like you know [ __ ] it's right
there that's a whole nother animal too
you know what i mean like the rap money
is good too i don't even be flexing that
[ __ ] but the right one is good too yeah
like everything goes away if you just
had your rap money you'd be living
nicely bro i could honestly live and
raise my family off the music and that's
the funny thing is be oh he's just a wee
guy or he's just this cookie that's cool
you could say all you want but
[ __ ]
the rap money's cool too i mean 20 uh 20
joints is gold or platinum gold yeah
small only gold uh well that and uh
i think i'm on
that's the only song i have that won't
go i think el chivo should be getting
close but that's gotta be close yeah
i never got a gold album though that's
my that's like my bucket list before i
die i gotta get a gold album i mean i
feel like
over time
one of your albums has got to get there
eventually like what what is your
biggest album
as far as like numbers wise like i think
uh
i think the biggest album number wise is
probably uh
it got to be like um i think pax did
really well packs are probably my
favorite packs it really well um
dude back in the days when you could
sell physical cds the below albums with
messy marvel did hella good too those
are the days oh [ __ ] went crazy bro like
i was selling like 15 000 physicals you
know i mean like and then whatever the
streaming side was so
i don't know i mean
i think that like um
i like being an underground artist so
because you have to understand like
mainstream artists they get a song on
the radio and then as soon as they come
off the radio they say they fell off
right if you look at my music career if
you're looking at business it's only
gone like this every year no i've never
shot up i've never had a straight home
run right but i've elevated every year
so if i get a record that hits hits i
got 42 album catalog to back that up so
that's not gonna ask you you really
don't have like a and i don't know if
anything's changed but you don't really
have like a manager per se
right now i don't have a manager i don't
even have a booking agent i actually
shout out to bobby d
uh uncle snoop's army he's been booking
me yeah um but i'm really just i'm a
sick [ __ ] kev i like to be hands on with
everything bro what's going to say
because i feel like you've had records
i feel like you put a bag behind a
record once i think it was the busy body
record
and what was the record that do you put
a bag behind a record was it the one
with this was like three or four years
ago
and i got mad because it didn't work huh
which one you got mad and i told you bro
you hired the wrong guy yeah
i think it was a busy body record bro
but i feel like you've had records that
like especially after that like records
of a boogie records with g records i
mean you've had some crazy records that
i mean there's the one with two chainz
whiz camron and [ __ ] um
someone else that should have been
should have been out of here like i just
should have been gone bro but i mean all
in a day was all in a day should have
been gone too all in a day i mean that's
old you know that's a lot older you know
i think that latino artists don't really
get the props they deserve bro it's a
way it's a weird like it's weird it's
really weird like it's hard to to break
through bro but i don't even try to
understand this [ __ ] no more i prefer
where i'm at like i see some of the
mainstream artists and i look at some of
the deals they're in and some of the
things they have to deal with and they
don't own their music like i'm happy
where i'm at i feel like you get to kind
of do what makes you happy in the music
industry without having to worry about
all the [ __ ] that makes people hate this
[ __ ] because you're dressed cause you're
just doing you there's no pressure
there's no pressure you built your own
world
yeah i'm good i mean we're down the
street right now knocking down some [ __ ]
bro and the music sounds it's probably
the best body of work i've ever created
and
there's no pressure
yeah i mean
you know you you always came through the
clutch with some great collab projects
uh i think my favorite collab album
you've ever done is probably the one
with mozzie
yeah man i think that's front to back
uh that's probably top three project of
years for me yeah because you know what
like the energy in there was like
it was like the best energy as far as
like like i've i was vibing off him he
was vibing off me and made me set my
game up but my beat selection is crazy
bro like i'm like an underground cali
when it comes to that i was gonna say
you got that rick ross here a little kid
yeah i got i got that good earlobe when
it comes to them beats and putting
artists on beats they usually don't rap
too like and that's why maybe i'm in the
position i'm at because i'll get a big
artist and put them on a sample beat
instead of like trying to go big but i
don't want to [ __ ] go big like i
don't want to be on the [ __ ] radio
bro yeah what is uh
like and you know there's been this
project with wiz that we've gotten
teased over for yeah i think it was
supposed to come out like two or three
christmases ago
like six years ago that was seven
i don't know man i know you guys
probably got a ton of records in the cut
no one's ever heard yeah they're sitting
there you know i just when the time is
right he'll let me know and you know if
he wants to drop it i'm down and i think
that you know
like there's a lot more records to make
and
i mean me and wiz make great music dude
like i have i have a really good year
for beats when it comes to him too like
i feel like i pick really good records
like with him you know what i mean like
i love and we bring like a certain kind
of energy out of each other like when i
pull up on him in the studio like he'll
bust out a different style that he ain't
really been using when it comes to stuff
that we do so i feel like when the me
and whiz album happen it's gonna be
powerful because we've been sitting on
it for so long so
you know when the time comes i think
people will be fired up who do you uh
is there any talks are you doing any
collab albums with anybody else right
now seems like we get one a year or so
yeah you know me and rose are supposed
to do one like a small ep like probably
three to six songs that's gonna be fire
you know what i mean like i can't wait
for that i've been actually saving like
a lot of mental space for that like if
you notice this year i dropped less
albums this year than i ever had because
i've been waiting for the rosette album
and then uh me and ozuna are doing like
a project it's not a it's not a groupon
we'll probably have like two or three
records together on there powerful ones
but we're going to use like our both of
our reach to put together like a sick
ass project just kind of based around
the brand we're building so you know
other artists from latin america from
here just create like a sick ass like
almost like a compilation but more like
a
maybe this will be like a annual project
like every other year or something like
that you and ross uh ross is somebody
who
i feel like has also kind of laid the
blueprint on how to be a successful
entrepreneur one of the easiest best
partners i've ever worked with i mean
he's one of the hardest working smartest
easiest partners i've ever had straight
up yeah because you've obviously
collaborated with a lot of artists on
the on that side of the game right and
i'm sure sometimes it's a little bit you
know things haven't worked out sometimes
and i'm sure you know some people are
just scared to use their platform to
promote the [ __ ] you're working on like
rose he's getting on instagram he's
pushing that [ __ ] he's not playing he's
a businessman and also he understands a
long term play you know my advice to a
lot of people out there a lot of people
are looking for that money right now
they want their money right now what can
i get right now there's power in
building equity you know what i mean
like when i look at my equity and
cookies alone like the weedside we
talked about the clothing side we look
at the weed side we're getting we're
gonna get there for sure yeah so i know
what my equity is i'm not i only take a
small salary from cookie's weasel i get
like a salary that's almost laughable
when
the type of [ __ ] i do but the equity is
there if i ever want to pull so he
understands that long-term play and
that's why me and jose work so good
together because he knows we're building
something that's super long-term
especially when we open up cookies
florida his brand's going to dominate
out there because he's been such an easy
guy to work with and we take that in the
back of him like when we open up florida
we're have four hundred thousand square
feet of indoor cultivation i'm a
petition heavy rotation we're probably
gonna make a store dedicated to his
brand colin zav fully decked out with
his logos everywhere like i just
appreciate the hard work and and the
vision and long-term play because there
is a big exit you know yeah let's let's
get let's let's kind of tap in uh to the
weed [ __ ] a bit like i said man you are
underappreciated under respected in this
game i always tell everybody
burner is richer than all of the rappers
like you know i don't even i don't even
try to think like that no but i i listen
i'll be having arguments with
[ __ ] for you when you ain't
around and i'll be like yo like legit
and i'm not saying no names but
i don't know anybody in hip-hop
outside of maybe [ __ ] dr dre or some
[ __ ]
maybe diddy you know maybe you know the
guys we think of and these are more
executives at this point but when we're
talking like
i don't know anybody who's who who's
[ __ ] with you when it comes to net
worth buddy at this point well if you
look at like cookies clothing cookies
cannabis if you look at buyer's papers
vibes is on a crazy
crazy run crazy traction like i i get
anxious thinking about that you think
about like equity and weed maps and you
look at stuff like g pen and santa cruz
shredder and you know things that people
forgot i have my hands in like there's a
crazy ecosystem of very valuable
companies and
it's kind of spooky sometimes man i just
you know
listen let me i heard a rumor that that
cookies was offered uh
pretty much to get bought for like close
to a billion dollars and you guys turned
that down is that true yeah now we get
crazy offers all the time someone was
just sitting down with us recently
trying to get us to go
take our [ __ ] out on the canadian
canadian stock market and whatnot and
the numbers they were talking about
there if we went out like it's crazy and
i just like the way i look at is like
that [ __ ] ain't real i just keep my head
down keep trying to focus on
you know
how do we keep this [ __ ] running i don't
even think because if you focus on the
numbers too much you'll get caught up in
that you'll get comfortable i'm never
comfortable you know we had we had this
[ __ ] set up at noon i was i'd text you
hell early could we do earlier yeah i
mean of course because i always work
right and i think i got that from my
pops you know i mean like i just never
really focus on it but to get to your
point yeah the net worth is probably
pretty pretty powerful right now and i
don't even know when or how that's going
to happen knocking on a billion
yeah probably i think so i think so i
mean i don't really know i mean i know
cookies is
i know next time we raise money for
cookies it's going to be in the multiple
billion so
just look at that like that well i mean
it seems as if too like
anytime there's a new market that
becomes legal
there's like three cookie stores that
open in the state straight up and then
you've got lemonade too and yeah and
lemonade is another brand that your
sister brand yes sister you don't want
to overwater every you know hella cookie
stores you know cookies like nike town
almost right but
we came with the sister brand lemonade
which is killing it too and um
i mean it's just it's crazy to think
about how much more growth there is i
mean there's latin america there's
europe and you and ozuna are doing
something in puerto rico right puerto
rico there's the east coast we didn't
even hit the east coast yo i was telling
man we were just talking about new york
my boy's like yo in new york when the
cookies hits new york oh my god it's
about to go crazy and i think the best
thing about our company is that we have
such a good team of breeders
um
and we're menu planning out for
100 years not right just right now i got
so much genetics in my hands right now
from all the breeders that we have
in-house and the ones we collaborate
with i can't treat it like beats i'll
sit down with the breeder we do a
breeding project i'm gonna pick a b c d
f g right boom i'll take these i'll tell
them just keep them at least a couple a
year whatever it is but we have so much
to next that we're planning out for 100
years so you know we're doing a really
cool [ __ ] right now where we'll film it
and be like yo
it's 2021 i'm sitting here
it's like a mexican chocolate i did with
bodhi shout out to bodhisees we're going
to take this i want to drop this in
2018. we're going to put this in tissue
culture this is the flavor profile and
if you work at cookies right now and you
you want to know why we're dropping this
this is why i like it and this is why i
want to name it and we're going to drop
in 2080 and we take that footage and we
put it away so one day maybe it'll be a
hologram or one day it'll be a video
message so maybe nft something right but
point being is i don't want to open up
all these stores around the world and
then have no purpose or no direction no
vision right like i thought it'd be cool
that we have hundreds of stores around
the globe right when i'm dead and gone
in the future they see a video of like
why we're releasing this strain why he
liked it why why he named it what it is
and it give my my employees and my team
and whoever is running them stores
[ __ ] vision bro like how these people
fired up like
a picture of you know colonel sanders
popped up and was like yo hey guys yeah
you know like i think people at them
drives who would take their [ __ ] a lot
serious you know a lot more serious so
we're planning out and that's my main
thing is like i don't get caught up in
the numbers of what cookies do i'm
getting caught up in how do i keep this
[ __ ] sustainable for a long time i want
to be a 100-year brand i don't want to
be a brand that's right now i'm going to
be popping later
um as you know we had a couple
interactions with a weirdo out in
arizona trying to make some stuff happen
out there but i've i've realized that in
the weed game there's a lot of [ __ ]
weirdos involved
there's a lot of emotions involved and a
lot of ego a lot of ego a lot of
emotions a lot of a lot of hate i mean
people try to knock what i do and i tell
them like this
i work with hundreds of partners and
operators it's the hardest thing ever to
do what we do yeah because for people
who don't know like
not all cookie stores are the same right
it's not like like you have to partner
with with people very strategic unique
model i said like this look
and going back to raising money the
reason why we turned down that that 800
mil back in the day is what was mostly
stock there was a good up front don't
get me wrong it was a lot of cash but
most of it was stock
but i decided to raise small right
i raised 20 million bucks
and i'm still working off that same 20
million dollars from that interview and
we stretched it and turned this [ __ ]
into a [ __ ] empire wow because we
decided instead of going out and buying
assets and building from the ground that
would take too long life's short take a
lot of money let's go ident and take a
lot of money which means a lot of
dilution that's why my net worth is high
because i kept my equity right so what
we did decided to do was
let's go around the world let's go
around the country and find operators
that are killing it right now right with
their stores that they have going right
now or with their girls they have going
right now
let's do a partnership with them that's
very rich in their favor for right now
right they keep a majority of the money
coming in right now but we get a roll-up
option on their stores we get a purchase
or store in the future right we get a
small rip-on percentage and we get to
have creative control of their
operations so
you empower a great grower in
new jersey give them their exit plan you
give them you give exactly you provide
them with exit plan but you empower
their knowledge and their skills i would
rather work with a bunch of talented
people than have to build everything for
it would take too long yeah it takes
it's a lot so our business model was
find
incredible operators from here to
wherever we're going empower them give
them our genetics give them our sops
make sure we have a great team on the
ground oversee the operation and build
right and it's worked [ __ ] incredible
it's for people who don't know it's it's
it's similar for for
people who aren't really enter into the
weed game would you say it's similar to
kind of like a franchise model nah it's
different it's like but you guys get to
curate
who
gets that exclu
cherry pick like i'll go to i'll go to
massachusetts for example you're not
gonna just let anyone get the cookies
brand it would be over it's quality
control involved you go to a market and
you find the best cultivator the best
operator and you go look at all of them
and what they're doing before they even
think about partnering with you and you
you cherry pick the best and you form a
partnership with them you pick who's
gonna do it so it's it's almost like a
franchise idea but totally different
except for you guys get to pick because
you're not gonna jeopardize i cannot the
brand because when we think of cookies
we think of uh
the best weed in the world yeah
yeah nah it's it's really cool so it's
kind of like a franchise but way
different because no one could just come
to us and say hey we got a hundred grand
let's let this get open nah it doesn't
work anybody can open a quiz nose you
can't open the cookies
you guys have to it's got to be a mutual
choice
have you had a situation where
uh you had a partner and it just didn't
end up working out or maybe they ended
up maybe fumbling or um that happens
that happens with everything i think
that we've done a really good job when
finding partners just like picking
because i've been in this for a long
time right you identified me and you had
a similar situation we talked about you
identified things right away like oh
this ain't gonna work yeah it's too
trippy we won't move forward with that
so i think that would have done a good
job of like judging character
kind of like finding the best you know
in class that we can find so we haven't
had too much problems but i think the
biggest problem we have is like denying
batches you know what i mean like we
have a very strong qc team right now and
it took a while to learn that like
i would lie if i didn't say there was
learning curves to expanding this fast
right but what we've done is like in
single markets we'll say hey we're not
we're not approving any of this like you
can go package under something else it's
not coming out it's not coming in our
bag yeah so it's hard that's the only
struggle is like we end up denying
sometimes more than we accept that's to
protect the brand i mean you can't just
put [ __ ] out 100
what would be some advice you know
because i i gotta imagine from your
perspective right you're
you know the one thing that i think
makes you different than a lot of
rappers who are trying to do the weed
thing is like your genuine
passion for the whole process
and not for just you know if we think of
a lot of these rappers they're just
trying to be you low-key they want
everybody wants their own cookies but
like you said earlier about ross
a lot of guys just want money now
they want to put they want to say hey
what's what's my money now looking like
as opposed to trying to really build a
brand and i feel like so many rappers
are just whoring their name out now in
the in in the weed space it's like kind
of crazy and and even
rappers that don't smoke
like a lot of rappers who do not smoke
weed yeah i'm not even talking about
like shout out to jay-z not a big smoker
but jay is a [ __ ] boss so i'd expect
jay to get into the cannabis game but
there's a lot of rappers who are
participating in the weed culture right
now that really have never been in the
weed culture is that kind of frustrating
for you to kind of i mean it doesn't
really matter at the end of the day but
is it is it
no i don't i don't even take it a
certain type of way the way i look at is
like this why do i do this still right
it's emotional it's crazy a lot of
dramas take probably taking years off my
life from stress but
i do it because i love it i i notice
that we really unites people it brings
people together from every different
walks of life
whether you're old young gay straight
[ __ ]
you know whatever i've seen we unite
people all around the world that's why i
do it right
two i love weed i'm obsessed with it
i've been doing it for so long so
i guess i say that that to say i'm
passionate about this [ __ ] when you're
passionate about something you really
live it and you walk and you understand
why you're doing it i don't think you
can even worry about no one else so i
welcome everyone getting in the game
with open arms but i think that they'll
burn themselves out because they might
not really be passionate about it
you go to my studio session right now
there's 42 jars laid on the table all
different names on them i got a notepad
next to those jars i'm just smoking them
taking notes on what i like and why i
like it and slowly putting them aside
and picking which ones i'm going to keep
which ones i'm going to give away it's a
[ __ ] process i love this [ __ ] i do
this [ __ ] i live eat and breathe this
[ __ ] so
you know the people that are in the game
that that want to just get in to get in
i think they'll just burn themselves out
what would be some advice you would give
someone watching this who is trying to
get i'm not even talking about rappers
just in general trying to get into
the legal side of the weed game start
from the ground up like i did learn the
business understand what you want to do
and why you'll be impactful in that in
that space and work your way up that
that's what i did
i mean i tell people all the time if you
want to get in the weed game go work at
a dispensary understand the consumer
understand
the vendor understand the grower
understand the tender the pos system
understand the bud tender understand how
to merchandise understand everything
before you get in decide what you want
to do do you want to be a designer you
want to be a grower you want to be a
store operator do you want to be do you
want to build a brand like what do you
want to do i think building a brand is a
lot more difficult than people think you
can't just take a [ __ ] t-shirt put
your logo on it put a bag with your logo
on it and now you got a brand there's a
lot deeper in that trust me i'm aware
and i think that like if you go back to
youtube i think the reason why cookies
resonated with people is i documented
every step of the process so if you're
going to build something document it
because you can go see me pulling
strings to my hoodies you know 15 years
10 years ago nine years on youtube on
youtube you can see me
making those hoodies selling that [ __ ]
you could see me in the dispensary way
long ago right like i've documented
every process of it so people resonate
with them they know it's real it's crazy
you mentioned branding because like you
have i feel like you could write a book
on how to brand i want to because i'm
trying to get a book deal right now yeah
because like if you think about the
cookies brand the color the cookies blue
just the logo just everything is so
two logos you got the font which is on
my hand you got the circle c by if they
ever say cookies can't be used because
it's you know attracting children
whatever they might use you got the
colorway if all else fails like i just
came with a straight identity bro and i
just
i just learned it from watching you know
watching the business i was in the
dispensary i noticed no one really had a
real brand that's like when you see that
blue you know what time it is
yeah what was the thought process behind
that color because that color it sticks
out it's
you know it was the first hoodie i made
bro for the yoko video like i just was
like give me like a like a different
blue like with the blue strings like i
just wanted to do something that would
pop on camera when i seen them like
that's my colorway right there it's a
wrap how important was that record yoko
for you man because that was a you know
that record also went to radio right and
i think you had a bag going for that
record you had big crit chris brown whiz
was that the first record you and wizard
did um
that was 2010 right
i think that that is the first
wiz song yeah it was
it was a big record for me and i think
that like there's a story behind that
[ __ ] that no one even knows about
whatever not just like the making of the
video was wild like
when i did that song
i ran into chris brown in the studio
right he was there i was smoking butt
his cousin smoked the bug was like oh
shot [ __ ] would you come eat brown god
brown in the video back then his manager
was tina davis she said all right well
he
we'll we'll prove him doing the record
we cannot do any video like video is not
happening wow whatever um so
i got the record done whiz big crit
chris brown
big [ __ ] made the beat [ __ ] was tech i
was like i gotta do a video for this
so
i was getting that brown's cousin he was
like look if you want to get chris to
come out you got to bring something dope
like he got held cars he likes to drive
his cars like think of a way you can
have him go provide an area for you know
for him to spin out in his cars or
something like come with something i'll
pitch it to him like all right cool so i
was thinking like maybe i can get a race
car track
so i called that uh nascar place in
irvine or whatever the [ __ ] this [ __ ]
was
and uh i asked him how much it was and i
said well what do you want to do i said
tomorrow he's like no like it's not
happening i'm like okay well how much is
it he's like well how much you got like
i got 1500. he laughed at me he's like
man like um
we wouldn't even run out the parking lot
for less than 15 g's and you want to use
the [ __ ] race track i'm sorry buddy
it's not happening i'm like what can i
come see you in person
he's like if you want to hear no to your
face come through i'm like for sure so i
pulled up over there
i met this guy square dude square ass
[ __ ] old dude
i was like yo um you know i'm here to
you know say yeah i don't really know
what to tell you kid you know it's not
happening i told you go in here no of
your face no
okay can you just do me one favor he's
like what i'm gonna go to your computer
he's like all right
i pull up with khalifa
on youtube and look at his views look at
his views like all right so i'm like go
to chris brown look at his views
pulls up he looks at the views he's like
if this is about like you think you're
going to give me promo look outside i
got coca-cola i got pepsi all these
places pay me money to be on my wall i'm
like it's not about that let me finish
go type in burner look at my views typed
in burner i'm like you see the
difference
i'm like bro like this guy ain't gonna
come do this video if i don't think of
something and i only have one day so if
you provide me this spot you can change
my life bro straight up but i just had
to hear no in person bro so i appreciate
you and the dude was like you know what
come here tomorrow save your 1500 bring
five for the ambulance and you could use
my racetrack i appreciate you coming
here i appreciate you telling me why why
it was important to you and i'll let you
use the place am i cool
so i leave
and we show up the next day
this guy's daughter was the biggest fan
of chris brown ever i guess he went home
and told her this guy brought down the
[ __ ] race car drivers that did the
video for otis for jay-z and conway what
this guy brought out [ __ ]
semi-fucking 18-wheeled trucks spinning
out in the video right
straight 150 000 production value at
least right let me do my thing there
brown pulled up the energy was crazy you
see them squashing around bro i only
spent 500 for that [ __ ] bro
on everything i love
on everything i love right like that
[ __ ] was crazy as [ __ ] and then you see
the scene where um
i'm driving the 18-wheeler
bro i went to atlanta and i went to
every i went to every truck stop where
all the truckers were resting and
knocked on [ __ ] doors and had a
thousand dollars and tried to convince
the driver to let me drive this [ __ ]
they called the cops on me twice
i finally got some cuddy nigerian dude
was like whatever you got a thousand
bucks it's yours i don't even know how
to drive people don't even know this i
don't even know how to drive i'm gonna
drive a [ __ ] car
oh you don't drive no
i drive a boat i'm driving a [ __ ] car
so i was let alone a [ __ ] uh semi the
guy was laying on the ground with his
foot on the [ __ ] gas holding the
pedal i'm sitting there riding in the
[ __ ] freeway bro
[ __ ] riding this [ __ ] rapping and the
guy's sweating dude like oh my god sir
we're done we're done i'm like nah nah
one more scene what we're seeing so that
video was hella crazy to me it's hella
important to me
now atlantic records put a cease and
desist on it for whatever reason which
makes no sense to me so it's not
available anymore but
it was big bro
i didn't that that that's crazy it's not
on youtube no it is but it's not the one
i put up with all the millions of views
someone like ripped it and put it on
their own channel or something yeah
that was was that and that was prior to
you being officially taylor gang correct
well it got it got pulled it got pulled
out when i was with taylor gang because
some dude um
i'm gonna say his name some dude took
the song and tried to do some licensing
deal with someone in [ __ ] europe and
the atlanta got pissed and [ __ ]
pulled it but
you know whatever yeah i was going to
ask you like you know the era of burner
and taylor gang like was a hell of a run
like um
you know obviously you and wizard always
fam you know what i'm saying but like
what
i guess
what did having that co-sign for you do
for you as a rapper you know what i'm
saying i just text wiz this morning and
thanked him bro i woke up this morning i
was just like bro i love you because
when i met you when i met wiz
my mom had just died from cancer right
so i was in a dark place i was trying to
get away from this street [ __ ] cause i
was really like
i was really [ __ ] with that [ __ ] bro
hard like people don't even know and i
don't really care you talk about a
little on your wraps yeah so you know
just use your imagination when you hear
that but at that time i was trying to
figure out a way because when my mom
died i was like well someone's got to be
here for my daughter if i go away
who's that going to be
my mom's gone now so [ __ ] it's me now so
i got to walk away from all that [ __ ]
and when i met wiz
i was able to meet him and taylor gang
and see the
the more the morale of the crew and see
the tour bus and they took me on two i
got to see what it looked like to go
state to state and perform it made me
step on my performance gang they brought
me in
and and they embrace you know the the
side of my life that i love most is
music so i just text quizzes more like i
love you bro thank you because when i
met you you gave me a spark i needed to
keep making music which is my passion
because other than that i might have
just went dark in the in the street [ __ ]
i might not be here right now
yeah i mean without getting into too
many details like was there ever a point
in time where like the street [ __ ]
almost ended up costing you freedom yeah
yeah not a big time
um i think that a lot of that [ __ ] will
be told in um
in this series i'm doing right now i
just announced a partnership with the
creator of snowfall
uh the writer director from denver
thieves and the producer of game of
thrones we're doing a we're doing a
scripted uh crime series about all about
pack shipping in northern california's
role in the wii game and so a lot of
them stories will be it's based on true
events so a lot of them stories will be
in there but yeah it definitely did bro
yeah it's crazy because if you think of
like and obviously
like you're you know northern california
was kind of like the hub for everyone to
go out there get their plug
and then
send packs to the midwest to the south
to just ever it comes to that granddaddy
purple and that og and that bubba kush
and like
just you know even with the cookies and
gelato i mean we nor cal really changed
the game especially look at like what
humble county did before people knew
what green greenhouse or outdoor was i
mean there's big margins my boy oh
especially on the outdoor [ __ ] yeah it
was almost like coke on you bro like
because if you think about like uh you
know if you have like some great light
depth or some great green
green house that's
on the east coast is loud at a certain
point in time before people knew what
greenhouse was i was dog walking people
bro
margin game insane bro like
it was nice time and then the game got
changed but yeah it's different now the
margins there was a period where people
from the south didn't know the
difference between indoor and outdoor
let alone indoor and greenhouse they
started figuring out outdoor because
obviously it looks way different it
smells right yeah but the good depths
and the good greenhouse would be so good
sometimes that pasta you couldn't tell
yeah
that's still going on uh yeah but not
but not to the same i'm sure in your
heyday it was man 4 800 for a pound of
green house
boy it was big yo it's crazy because you
mentioned humble i just watched this uh
me and my wife watched this documentary
on hulu um
murder mountain no it's it's it's it's
on the bigfoot the sasquatch yes
yeah yeah i forget what is finding
sasquatch i think yeah that [ __ ] is
crazy up there there's a lot of until
stories and that's what my whole goal is
with that series is to tell northern
california's you know story did you ever
get like into that world up in humboldt
county and uh absolutely because that
world is crazy man like there's people
who go up there and don't come back down
yeah not you know humble it's uh
humble's a beautiful place there's great
people up there there's a dark side
everywhere you go but i'm bullets like
they almost there's it's almost like
it's own laws up there loki like oh you
get in the hills it's a whole nother
story you know i can't wait to that's
why i've been waiting though because a
lot of my stories are coming out in the
series there's been some crazy give me
give me one crazy story that that you
could give us just just give me one bro
give me one uh well as a trailer for the
series well one story was uh
i was up there with the buyer and we
went to uh to go by maybe like 100 ogs
or something like that and we drove up
to like a mountain so there's a gate on
the bottom of the hill
and my dude came down and grabbed the
bread i was like i'll be right back cool
i'm sitting there with this buyer and he
drives up this hill
and we're chilling it's kind of hot day
and time just keeps going by it's not
coming back down i'm just like damn
looking at my watch i'm like damn what's
up go to my phone no service i'm like
[ __ ] a little nervous and dude's chain
smoking cigarettes i'm with the buyer
it's changing someone can serious
he's like yo
go up there i'm like i'm not [ __ ]
going up there bro [ __ ] talking about
he's like go up there bro you get my
money this dude go up there i'm like man
i don't know what's up there i don't
know how far it is he's like you're
gonna go up there bro he's like it's
been about 45 minutes to do say he'll be
right back go up there like i'm not
going up there dude pulls out a gun
[ __ ] it back say burn i am trying to go
there bro but you need to go up there
i'm like [ __ ] dude all right hop over
the little shady fence start walking i
walk for like 10 minutes bro i'm looking
up this road it's just not stopping i'm
like stripping sweat i come back down
like bro
i don't even see an end to this trail
i'm not gonna go i i walked for 10
minutes bro i'm [ __ ] sweating like
[ __ ] it's hot as [ __ ] i don't know what
to tell you he's like that [ __ ]
played us that [ __ ] drove up
the hill with my money and drove down
and left he's like he played this you
[ __ ] robbed me he's holding his gun
my bro i didn't not robbie starts
honking his horn honking his horn starts
tripping
my bro just breathe we're gonna figure
it out it's all good it's all good it's
all good bro it's all good he's looking
at me crazy honking his horn i'm like
this motherfucker's about to shoot me
for sure i'm about to get shot and then
also my boy comes down that [ __ ] hill
i'm looking at this too and he's like my
bad bride would trim up a few more to
make it even hundred i'm like
[ __ ] dude i started walking up
that hill trying to find he was like oh
dude it's like a mile and a half [ __ ]
drive you wouldn't [ __ ] you wouldn't
have made it up the hill like maybe
maybe if you were to walk forever you
know and i was like damn god damn bro
and the crazy thing about that story was
i took my little i took my little piece
you know me and my boy took my little
issue from the side when he went up the
hill he gave me my bag i gave it to a
little pretty [ __ ] to go ahead and dip
off i opted i hopped in a separate car
to leave i'm smoking a joint we're
driving and the dude was so stressed out
bro
literally i cannot make this [ __ ] up
we're leaving humboldt county there's
like a little area by um
some place called uh
right when you get into mendo um
but we're we're pulling off and this
dude's pulled over bro
we passed them i'm sitting there smoking
and i've thought to get paranoid for a
second but i don't have anything in the
car but the weed i just took a couple
the chick had all my little cut whatever
i made she was already long gone but
they had this food pulled over dude
he had a bad day
he had a very bad and he had everything
on him he had 100 pack on him yeah and
they pulled him over yeah did they end
up he had a bad day i never talked to
him again brother i just wow ghosts
well it's crazy it's like that's what
people don't know like in the wii game
like a lot of like if
middleman and [ __ ] is a great it's a
great little hustle it was good for me
you know back then but it just came with
it came with a lot of stress and
you know i think what happened to dude
man like he just
he was from out of town he was anxious
he just got profiled leaving that place
and
i don't think they care about the
hunting pack i don't think they took
them to jail they was looking for money
them cops out there want money sometimes
bro just to shake you down because they
know what they know what you're doing
they probably took your [ __ ]
you know what i mean so
yeah man like
the game is not pretty bro how much
money did the guy go up the hill with
100 pack i mean [ __ ] what i don't
remember what the prices were back then
bro
100 pack og
i gave him like a
probably 40
probably forty two hundred and forty
forty five hundred each back then you
know i mean
that's a lot of bread it's a lot of
bread yeah
yeah that's that's that's the who's
gonna shoot my ass bro i've seen in his
eyes
yeah
he's gonna shoot me and then the guy
comes down the mountain [ __ ] bro
hippie [ __ ] bro hella cool hella
calm collective we're sitting there
dripping sweat it's hot up there bro
it's hot day hey what up man we got to
interrupt the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at odd socks
now when i be riding for odd socks so
hard man it's because i really love the
product they got the most comfortable
socks in the [ __ ] world i got a pair
of odd socks basics on right now go get
those they got the socks wwe joints you
know i'm saying shout out to the
undertaker pepsi [ __ ] really
whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the ww they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview as far as like um
you know during that period i feel like
it's kind of like a golden era of like a
certain moment in the weed game like any
of your peers in that game also kind of
level up with you at the same time and
and
are also kind of doing their thing yeah
good amount of people i love to see
people from the original market and you
know the new market right now like
actually in the legalization market so
shout out to everyone that's like
a lot of people think that i be people
or people that beef with me i think it's
like a
it's a very small community it's a big
business but a very small community and
i think that everyone that's killing
killing it right now i salute them i
congratulate them they made it past like
a very weird gray dangerous area and now
they're in like a new area but era but i
think this is like timeless and it's
history and being a part of history is
tight do you ever find it like
frustrating that you can't be
you know i i've talked to certain
artists uh some from your hometown
that are kind of like
nonchalantly feel like there's some hate
or some weirdo [ __ ] towards you um
is it hard to be burner and like not
being like like you can't be everything
to everybody right
and especially when it comes to like
that [ __ ] like is it is it like kind of
like
because you keep a small circle around
you my bubble's super small it's super
tight it's super small it's been that
way for a long time like is that on
purpose because of that kind of [ __ ]
because everybody wants access to you
bro yeah you know
access is denied right now bro like
limited access for sure because energy
is everything time is everything life is
short you gotta enjoy this [ __ ] while
you can you know i mean you never know
what could happen whether it be cancer
or [ __ ] covert or a [ __ ] kid buy a
car so i keep my circle tight do people
are people mad about it maybe i just
don't give a [ __ ] like
there's only one opinion i care about
it's my daughter's you know i mean and
my wife's and that
i really focus on my daughter's opinion
i really care what she thinks about me
anyone else
[ __ ] him straight up i am worried about
it are you uh tapping with i know you
got caps which is like more of like a
mushroom yeah but but are you gonna
eventually with the legalization of
shrooms hell yeah that's why we set up
already like we're doing what we can do
legally but i mean a lot of my partners
on the cannabis side are mushroom
enthusiasts and they know a lot about
mushrooms and they're fired up on it and
so
we're just trying to make sure we're in
position for when it comes we're gonna
that's a whole another side of the
business yeah i feel like that's like
the future low-key yeah i just saw a
money man post some [ __ ] on twitter
about shrooms like he's like yo perks
and zans are dead rappers
if anyone's listening to this man
like pills coke oh it's just super
dangerous man like the fentanyl problem
right now is real i feel like there's a
reason why there's a lot of fentanyl out
here in the streets and i think that
people are purposely flooding america
with fentanyl for people to harm
themselves put the [ __ ] lien down
that's just disgusting i can't believe
people are still sipping everybody did
you ever go through an arrow with lean
[ __ ] no look at my eyes or clear his
bright daylight right now i'm into the
bag right now yeah i mean i smoke blood
and that's it but
um you know lean is all bad bro i'm
seeing people [ __ ] their whole lives
are [ __ ] ruined from this you don't
even understand bro yeah nah it's it's
it's crazy because like you said the
fentanyl [ __ ] i feel like fentanyl is
like
it's like
low-key as big of an epidemic of covet
just people ain't talking about it like
that because it's out there you don't
know what you're getting and
how pure it is and fentanyl is killing a
lot of people it was i don't know if you
saw like in venice there was like a
house with like four comedians they left
a comedy show and three out of four died
doing coke but it was it was cut with
fat you can't push it in your body right
now if you know where it's coming from
you know i mean alternative plant
medicine man stick with the weeds stick
with the shroom stick with you know just
stick with [ __ ] that's natural don't
don't touch that [ __ ] yeah and for
people who don't know too like we like
you know because a lot of the
issue with getting off that [ __ ] is the
withdrawals and [ __ ] but you [ __ ] dab
away those withdrawals
straight up
like straight up man the drugs down man
put put the drugs down uh you're you
have a lot of interest in alien [ __ ] um
we did some [ __ ] on clubhouse we had
like a little alien room on clubhouse or
in the pandemic but like
you also kind of have you know you
you've got some conspiracies that you're
tapped in with
but what you know i i think that like
with the
obama admitting ufos are real
i just feel like
because the world's so crazy right now
because of trump because of kovid
because all this wild [ __ ] they're like
throwing [ __ ]
out right now because they know it's not
going to be the main story they have to
just cover their tracks they're letting
it come out and just get you know
overwhelmed with other [ __ ] yeah because
i feel like i feel like again they're
getting everyone ready for some [ __ ]
low-key
i mean if we think that our government
hasn't been to another planet yet we're
probably pretty crazy if you ever go
outside at night and just look up look
up there and if you're in a clear area
like when i was in montana i would go on
my boat at nighttime midnight one
o'clock in the morning flood out to mill
lake with no lights and just lay there
and you see all these [ __ ] stars and
planets
you don't think there's some other [ __ ]
up there you're [ __ ] lost
there's a hell of other [ __ ] up there
and
i think the i think earth is just being
burnt out it's overpopulated there's a
lot of weird [ __ ] going on there's a lot
of
um there's a lot of control issues and
people want to be in power other
countries want to be in power i
definitely feel like there's other other
planets out there that we've been to or
that we can go to and
that's why you see bezos
i was gonna say that's why i think these
you see these billionaires trying to
they're trying to they're gonna be the
first people to leave because i i
honestly feel like the government
suppressed
how easy it really might be to get up
there right like they're just telling
you it's not possible you gotta get this
big rock and do this and i'm
how the [ __ ] do we know that you look at
you look at [ __ ] and they say it's this
far it takes that mile might all be some
[ __ ] you might be able to get in
something just get up so i don't know
but i definitely know there's more
people there's more there's more species
out there than just us we're not we're
not like the dominant species we've
we've been put here by something else
our body is designed like a [ __ ]
computer dna is designed like a [ __ ]
computer it's not
we didn't we didn't just
germans didn't just [ __ ] calculate
and design us like we were designed on
purpose so that's my thoughts do you um
have you ever had a ufo experience where
you seen something yeah
yeah i had a in vegas i was in vegas
randomly at molly mall's house
shout out to molly mom yeah yeah
legendary home yeah a lot of a lot of
great stuff happened over there but yeah
no it's crazy because
when i was growing up
my mom's
uncle
was like a og at nasa
og at nasa so she went to maryland to
visit uh her aunt and her aunt's husband
who worked at nasa at the time his name
was doc
and uh my mom asked him if aliens are
real
and he said it
he couldn't tell her
but if people knew what was in the ocean
a lot of people want to kill themselves
yeah nah dude i mean that's just stuck
with me my emotions one of my monkeys
friends when i was growing up
his grandpa was the super super
decorated war veteran
and like very straight edge very square
like
super like just legit and when he was
dying he told my best friend
man just i had to keep this to my
deathbed but there's definitely aliens
out there i've definitely seen things
and you should know we're not alone i
just want to share that with you and
that's just stuck with me too but you
guys gotta be realistic man there's no
way we're the only people out here and
i've been even thinking like i've been
really reading on
lately like life after death like maybe
this is just one big audition for like
what happens next like i look at my dog
sometimes like this motherfucker's been
here before
he's he was he's been here before and i
start geeking out on that and i really
i'm really into like what happens when
you die type [ __ ] right now are you like
would you consider yourself religious no
because i'm not i'm not at all either i
i i'm borderline atheist i'm borderline
i don't know i i don't know i get in
trouble a lot when people ask me about
religion but i'll be straightforward i
believe that we were put here by
something if you look at religion right
every single religion whether it be
whatever country whatever religion it is
they all say that someone came from
above
came down taught them and went back up
no [ __ ] brainerd
yeah i've always kind of been
a lot of that [ __ ] is man-made they all
got the same themes for the most part
some are literally i mean i just feel
like they all experienced the same thing
someone came from above
taught them and went back up what does
that mean um
i mean even like the hieroglyphics
there's some wild hieroglyphics where
it's like [ __ ] were bird humans
and all kinds of [ __ ] so i i like to get
high bro when my day ends i have like 18
hour 19 hour work day whatever the [ __ ]
it is i get home the last few hours of
my day i just get high and i google as
much as i can you just did you you dive
down some youtube rabbit holes
big time especially in the last two
years yeah because you've had time i got
time i got time cuz but besides smoking
and uh and you know being uh
entrepreneur you know [ __ ]
entrepreneur [ __ ] boss uh
what do you what are your you know
family life aside what are your like
you know what's a good day for you
hobby-wise like if you had to wake up
and just do whatever you wanted to do
you know
what are your hobbies man
[ __ ] hobbies right now is just the film
stuff which is still work like
um i did a comedy with ed bassmaster
shout out to homie ed
we just freezed out that and we're about
to put that out soon i got a movie
called splash city all about
the bibing in the bay area i really want
to bring to life like northern
california crime stories and like just
northern california is on tap like if
you really look at a lot of crime films
or movies in general based on l.a well
especially
on a commercial worldwide level yeah
there's nothing
out the band i feel like that's my job
right so
my hobby now is just developing content
uh barrier-based like and it's [ __ ] up
it's not really a hobby i guess it's
like work but
that's what i like to do yeah so the
show that you're developing with uh the
snowfall people
that's like a big deal it's a really big
deal that's like that's not like some
like independent like rap [ __ ] nah but
see the thing is like i also understand
that we're gonna raise like 70 to 80
million to do that project and it's
gonna take time so in between that while
developing that i'm trying to knock out
all this [ __ ] learn the game yeah i'm
trying to do like an independent like
the splash city it's like me and um a
group called uh four ways entertainment
they just wanna they wanted a latin film
festival for the movie called slipping
in darkness i just i appreciate their
hustle their work ethic i locked in with
them i'm like come to the bay let me
write this movie let me direct it with
you you guys execute it we'll edit it
together and i'll put it out so that
that way while i'm developing this
series people start getting a sense of
my style when it comes to film [ __ ]
everyone's got their own style you got
scorsese you got you know spike lee
[ __ ] rob zombie he was an artist he got
his own style got his own style yeah my
style is gritty it's real gritty i see a
lot of these crime series on tv right
now a lot of them are a little too
pretty for me they're too pretty they're
too produced like let's bring some edgy
[ __ ] back like menace the society was so
sick dude oh yeah it meant yeah raw as
[ __ ] like
we need that [ __ ] back bro some of this
shit's too pretty bro i think the last
show that really did that for me was the
wire
the wire was great i think the last show
did it for me was breaking bad
breaking bad was raw as [ __ ] yeah it was
good
it was produced but it was good it felt
real that's real do you watch better
call saul
just been on i'm solid solid but a
perfect day for me would be wake up six
a.m
make my green juice or drink a green
juice work out chill with the dogs play
on my phone till my [ __ ] starts ringing
get some work done go to my daughter's
volleyball game
watch her make some dinner for the kids
you know watch a good couple crime
movies and relax like that'd be my
perfect day not these hectic days where
it's just back-to-back calls like
until i go to bed those days hurt like
sometimes because they suck they drain
yeah bro the other day i had a day bro
like i started first call 6 30 a.m i got
off at 11 p.m
and i just felt like what the [ __ ] am i
doing bro you know am i spread then is
there too much going on i just had to
breathe and digging a chance to work out
didn't get a chance to chill with the
fan but
the day man is what it is
you're gonna have those kind of days man
you know you're kind of you got like a
you're inside man like you probably know
more than most people is they're like
like what do you think the realistic uh
chances are of weed coming off the
federal federal
drug list
i should i want to say that it's going
to happen because it'd be a great day
for me but i don't see it happening
anytime soon
you don't think it's gonna happen
because you think it because at the end
of the day if
new york is finally on do you think it's
just gonna have to be a state by state
thing it's gonna be gray area for a long
time i think the feds and the government
want to figure out how to milk every
single part of the business and until
they figure that out they're not gonna
do it but
sleepy joe ain't gonna let that [ __ ]
happen bro that boy's tired as hell you
know he's turning this [ __ ] into china
2.0 right now i'm not gonna lie i voted
for joe biden yeah but
man i didn't vote this time
it was less than two evils for me it was
damned if you do damage if you don't but
damn sleepy joe is [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] up right now
the entire bastard's on the ward path
but you know what is what it is and i i
don't see his administration legalizing
whedon and what's crazy is they promised
it he they promised it that's what their
whole market that's they was talking
about that [ __ ] and they ain't doing
nothing yeah i know it's it's it's bad
man i don't know you know what like you
said damned if you do damned if you
don't that boy a cup of coffee man yeah
man yeah yeah have you guys ever like
done any like you know
[ __ ] when we think of uh cigarette
companies do lobbyist [ __ ] have you guys
ever done some lobbyist [ __ ] no i don't
trust that [ __ ] yeah i'm a lobby myself
is it weird though cause now all these
corporate [ __ ] are like coming
into the weed game trying to buy out
these companies and and i feel like kind
of [ __ ] it up low-key like i mean
i've talked to a bunch of them i'm not
doing that
if i ever exit bro if i exit if there's
ever a liquidity event for me they
understand there's like
major major major major major protection
of the brain involved like no one's
trying to do that
my goal is to pass this [ __ ] to my
daughter to be honest with you i tease
her all the time you're about to be a
little ceo you better learn the game and
she already has a clothing line yeah
that's why i did that
she understands
that's big man and i never you notice i
don't really promote her [ __ ] like that
because i'm making her and her make her
figure out you got to figure it out
how's it doing it does cool it could do
a lot better but and i'm sure if i post
it every day and every drop i'd probably
do way better but i want her to learn
the struggles i don't want to just give
her everything she's got to work for it
but like me and her bond by like designs
and like
we could flip a jacket like this or you
could do like this or you can and she's
really proud of her [ __ ] and she wears
it to school and
i couldn't be more proud of her but i
wanted to learn that [ __ ] hands-on you
know
how was um settling down for you because
you know you you had your days i was a
wild boy he was a wild boy
he was a wild boy i was a wild boy
settling down for me was good
yeah cause i feel like you know
you know for me too like i was a wild
boy for sure
you don't even know i was wild but you
know what though like
it feels so much better not having to
deal with that [ __ ] like you know how it
should be multiple girls and phones and
hiding in this i can't even think about
doing that right now yeah i think too
like once you've done everything
it's like man you like there's almost
only so much of the of that [ __ ] you
could do i did it all i was a bartender
before any of this so you gotta remember
that when i was working at the hempson i
was a bartender at 18. you have to
understand i did it all i did it all
right it was amazing i was young my hair
was slick back it was skinny it was
incredible but
i think that settling down leveled up my
business
yeah for sure like it it took me from
like hood rich to
in a great place straight up yeah i feel
like since i got married to my wife
everything is improved shout out to our
wives shout out to the wife
because if i wasn't if i wasn't able to
go to like when i'm here working or if
i'm traveling if i didn't know that my
household was good and my daughter was
straight when she's at my house because
my daughter's been at the house with my
wife now
for like five days and she hasn't even
went back to her mom's house you know so
it's it's perfect because i know i have
a solid household and that [ __ ] does
numbers for your money mentally yeah
when you're gone you know everything's
handled yeah yeah now same thing with my
wife i'm like yo i could be at in miami
for a whole week and i know i don't got
to worry about it i get yelled at for
not cleaning now now you know here and
there but at the end of the day settling
down made me like a very successful
business guy i see a lot of my friends
caught up with hello girls and [ __ ] that
shit's ass backwards if you want to get
to the bag have a wife hey
that's a bar if you want to get to the
bag have a wife straight up and happy
wife happy life
[ __ ] facts [ __ ] facts yes have you
uh considered i know you uh you
mentioned montana earlier but have you
considered like
switching your primary residency out of
california
yeah but i just don't know where i would
go um
you know a lot of people in my position
because you have to think like if i sold
my business with the new body in the
administration's law i was like i
probably have to give 68
i think it's 68 federal something crazy
i don't know i don't know i don't want
to speak on it because i don't know i
would end up keeping like 15 of my
business profits right like so i don't
know i can't do miami miami's too humid
humid vegas is kind of like too dry for
me um those to survive though those are
the two like places where you know tax
yeah you could really save money and and
if you really wanted to be a savage you
can go to puerto rico no federal tax
that's [ __ ] wild so you can get a 100
million dollar check go to puerto rico
live there for three years and all that
money is yours
i think that's uh logan paul just
relocated to puerto rico did you share
the [ __ ] did i but the way i look at
it's like this bro
i just want to be where i want to be i'm
not going to go hide somewhere for x in
my years to say i just
vegas ain't bad you know i used to live
in vegas i know this is cool it's hot
though bro it's dry i mean you lived in
arizona i did i don't want to go back
yeah it's too hot it is so hot i'm a
cool player man yeah yeah yeah how many
years were you in az i think on and off
for like five years and that was because
your mom was out there yeah my dad was
supposed to open a restaurant out there
so and there was cheap housing and so we
going to go move over there and then my
pops got caught up with some cheating
and whatnot so we stayed in california
my mom stayed there and i just bounced
back and forth and uh what part of of a
z were you in chandler oh you were in
the chandler people don't know man
chandler ain't nothing sweet certain
parts of chandler ain't that sweet man
come on chandler arizona is really a
wild place
it is
people don't believe me i'm like listen
guys arizona is different everyone has a
gun
i mean i was selling acid in the sixth
grade in arizona
wow
a [ __ ]
put a pinky nail out and had me hit
crystal meth in class in seventh grade
in class in chandler i thought it was
coke it was [ __ ] crystal arizona's
turnt up
so he was up for two days so you did
math in seventh grade on accident
you did meth by she was such a pretty
[ __ ] she had long ass curly hair big
ass earrings yeah julius is a cartel
baby for show
she had this long ass nail she said hey
look at this
take a little bump
i'm like oh [ __ ] i started feeling like
oh [ __ ] what's that [ __ ] burn shut up
that was mad i'm like oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] i was on one for two days i was
[ __ ] up dude it was [ __ ] up did you
ever go through like uh you know
obviously outside of just experimenting
with drugs you ever go through like a
time where you were like doing coke on a
regular basis i was cooking for a while
yeah yeah what years were it was i was
bartending bro yeah because i said i did
it all dude when i was 18 18 like
18 to like 20 21 or 23 i was just you
were wow
doing coke right
molly now molly just coke because
friday night was
friday night was hip-hop
saturday night was techno and then
sunday night was salsa and all the
[ __ ] cubans and colombians would come
and they all found i was only 18 19
right i was [ __ ] all the [ __ ] oh
man they kept giving me bumps key shots
gave me like eight balls while i was
working it was just part of the culture
and the bartender lifestyle is very
shady very dirty lifestyle just coke
coke coke liquor
and i was finally one day i was like i
can't do this [ __ ] no more i'm over this
[ __ ] dude i almost od that reggae in the
river that's what it was oh [ __ ] that's
why i stopped doing coke
reagan in the river what is that it's a
festival in northern california where
it's on the river it's hot as hell i was
on coke and graders grey goose for three
days
i turned pale and i dropped and i woke
up at the medics and like yo dude you
gotta you gotta just chill it out a
little bit and i remember i went home to
my chick's house and i did a bump and my
heart started doing the same thing it
did when i fainted i was all right
that's it i'm done i don't want to die
that was it it's over i was about to
have a baby too
so
it was a wrap yeah never never and
that's why i don't drink to this day
though
because and that's why i don't drink
because when i drink it the combination
of cocaine and alcohol is powerful yeah
it's a great one
i've never done cocaine but i know that
the people who i know who i'm still
close with that's their thing is they
get drunk and they do coke yeah because
you could just keep going yeah but i'm
glad i stopped that [ __ ] how long it's
been what uh janelle is 14. it's been 15
years since i touched that or alcohol
wait so you haven't drank in 15 years
i've maybe had like a couple sips or
maybe with wiz i took like one or two
shots but i don't drink drink no i don't
know yeah no yeah no you're right
because i've seen you like at dre's and
like you're just
just there smoking yeah
yeah alcohol is like i'm not alcoholic
but i understand like
i like i like the social lubricant of
like you know if i go out just having
some shots and
i never dealt with i never dealt with
doing coke i've never i'm glad i don't
drink man like whiz is the only one that
could pressure me to drink because we
laugh hella hard but my version of
drinking it's like two or three shots
that's it thank you take some of this
gin and lemonade yeah or just some of
this is a queen just take this gin
straight yeah i don't understand that
about whiz is that they like gin is
disgusting by itself guys he made jin
cool he did straight up bombay and
lemonade that's a good mixed drink but
by itself it's like drinking gasoline
bro [ __ ] that it's it's it's it's
horrible was there ever a point in time
where you had an opportunity to maybe do
something on the major label side where
you just kind of kept kept it moving
because i know you know you've been
you've been doing the distro with empire
since i really feel like since empire
was ever even a thing [ __ ] major labels
dude they never understood me they never
wanted to take the time to understand me
it's probably their biggest mistake
because
i mean they probably would have had a
piece everything i'm doing now so
i sat down with a couple and they just
did not understand me it never took the
time to understand how early on were did
you link with ghazi
for 2006 2005 or six was that when he
was rapping
um nah he was at uh ingress okay yeah
yeah so he left in groups started empire
and so from the rip were you just doing
distro through his company now i was the
in grooves and one day told me yo i
moved your catalog over to my new
company i'm like what the [ __ ] you
talking about bro i would like you now
you're gonna get the same check i'm
gonna give you a better split just trust
me and i was one of his first clients
and yeah and it's you know i always tell
people like
empire is the [ __ ] check comes every
month on the first
i tell some of these major label artists
how much i get for itunes checks and
they're like what the [ __ ] are you
serious well they're idiots they signed
all their leverage away they [ __ ] a
lot of these major artists they signed
too early i feel bad because when i tell
them how much i get from just my empire
check along you could see their eyes
like
what well because most artists aren't
getting any money i don't get anything
they're literally they got to make their
advance last because they're not going
to ever recoup
you know uh we did an interview with yg
a couple of years maybe like middle of
the pandemic
he was like i've never seen any money
off my def jam [ __ ] he's one of the
dopest guys ever that's funny he's the
best yeah it's terrible and at the time
he was like on some [ __ ] def jam [ __ ]
but like it's crazy because that story
is happens a lot if someone's gonna give
you some money
up front there's probably a bunch of
[ __ ] that comes with it a thousand
i'm glad i did it the way i did yeah i
always tell everybody man don't take the
bigger the advance
you better make it the longer you got to
make it last it kept a certain hunger
inside me too i like being the underdog
that's that what's your favorite burner
album
like you just said you're working on
your best album yet i've heard you say
that almost every time you put out my
but what's your favorite ever um
[ __ ] dude they're all still like
journals dude i don't know i mean i
think the wide out i think drugstore
cowboy is a good one i think with the
white album was really really good too
um but the reason why i say this the
best i'm done now is because i got cosmo
producing it it's my best friend we work
great together i love you you guys just
did a collab album yeah i really leveled
them up on the way that we're doing the
production of the project i gave them
free range like instead of me just being
in the studio like send me a beat them
by the wrap like we're just spending 10
days i'm just producing this thing
and then i'm gonna take that production
come back you know
five days six days from now and then
really just dive into like recording so
i like this body work as we're actually
really doing it like from scratch yeah
like from the red samples i'm not
getting sued anymore there's people
playing guitars people doing vocals like
it's really cool you had like a era with
um
el chivo where
you
were diving a lot into collaborating
with a latin artist and i know that you
had kind of flirted with the idea of
maybe doing an album with dell records
yeah um shout out to dell yeah i mean
the record is incredible shout out to
chris i think i think uh
i was dj on one of your shows i think i
was in vegas at uh hard rock and chris
came out and sang and yeah um but that
was
like what did you learn from kind of
dabbling in that side of the game
because the you know the latin [ __ ] is
crazy i just was in the latin billboards
for a whole week because my artist is
mexican so we were out there i just
learned a different world of the world
out there and i think what we did with
the el chivo records we took hip hop and
their traditional like style of making
music and combined it and it was like
the first
of that kind like we flipped the nos
beat dude yeah i mean like we flipped
the old naz record and
we did it like that and so i think that
no one's really tried and i kept to what
i do i rapped in english he sang in
spanish it was a great natural
combination of music and i mean i would
love to sit down with them and do a
project with them i'm down and do album
with him for sure and produce everything
alive and documented like that's kind of
[ __ ] that would be funny because you
were like starting to work with a lot of
latin artists uh
obviously ozuna i try i tried it with la
plaza i tried it but like it just it's
tough man like it's music is tough like
people people enjoyed it and music
actually was really good but my core fan
base complained a little bit so it's
tough to dial that in you know what was
it like um
working with nipsey on the wax room and
like what
best rest in peace and nipsey i mean i
made the record i'm gonna tell this
story i never really told this story
either i made the record
i hit up nipsey me and nipsey talked a
lot in dm and nipsey's the one rapper
one of the only rappers that respected
me as a musician
he respected my music he gave me my
props all the time on the music
i talked a lot with him in the gm and um
you know text back and forth and so i
hit him i was like i got his record he's
like pull up
[ __ ] hopped in uber pulled up by myself
his studio was hella deep hello
hello homies they're all so welcoming to
me we started blazing he won the booth
he did his his vocals
killed it gave me the session i went
right back to my studio mixed it and we
came time for the video
i came out to la to do the video
and he didn't he i was blown away he
didn't show up i was like [ __ ] he faked
on me i was blowing him up i'm like you
know what [ __ ] it it's cool and the next
day he hit me like my bad bro i was
dealing with some [ __ ] like some real
[ __ ] but i got you send the camera guy
to me and knock that out for you i'll
take care of it i'll pay him too i got
you i'm like oh man you sure he's like
yeah
he knocked it out bro he knocked out his
scenes for me send it to me it was it
was perfect bro like i gave that guy so
much respect on what kind of person he
was what kind of business guy he was
um so he showed me a lot of love yeah i
think like he he also too like you know
the way you're kind of showing people
there's there's a whole nother way you
could go with this [ __ ]
he did a good job of showing people the
same way you know what i'm saying yeah
nah i mean dude
[ __ ] that guy's the best i think the
last time i talked to him he told me you
did for the word cookies what dr dre did
for the word chronic i can't even say
cookies without people thinking it's
sweet
props bro you really did that [ __ ]
that's the last time i talked to him
yeah i mean what was the origin of
cookies because i always hear different
stories right that like you were behind
that girl the original strain or your
people were behind the original strain
that we were the original [ __ ] was
called girl scout cookies but we knew we
were gonna get suits i just called the
cookies i think the first time i ever
smoked it was with two chains at molly
moss house in vegas in like 2010 or
eleven
two changes my boy two i like two chains
man it's a cool cat
yeah yeah yeah okay
i don't know if he's doing anything in
the weed game but i feel like he should
be he's a man bro like i i dm with him a
lot too just [ __ ] and he's cool i
like two chains yeah chain's a good dude
who's besides
you know uh let's take ross wiz
the immediate guys we know you to be
really close with who would you consider
to be like a true friend in the rap game
that you've encountered because we have
a lot of accomplices
mozzie
he's a good friend bro
we talk about life we don't we don't
really talk about
politics or that we talk about life kids
business
um you know just life bro i like mozzie
would you do a sequel hell yeah
i'm working on this [ __ ] right now
that'd be crazy yeah i need that that
first one is gonna be hard to top man
this is gonna be easy you guys got you
got logic on the song with mozzie yeah
exactly you know what that song is
cracking on spotify right now it's it's
probably when mazzy's number one songs
on spotify just found this out out of
nowhere it just happened like no it is
it's it's it's uh i i just was on
mozzie's profile and it was in the top
five yeah it just happened like a couple
months ago but yeah [ __ ] logical what
cuz like for a while there you were you
were you were linking with logic a lot
um i was trying to do something with him
but you know he's he's a busy guy man
you know he's he's i know he started
smoking and getting you know logic
smokes man no i know but he used to not
yeah he used to be a drinker yeah he
likes sweet so you guys were trying to
because i know he pulled up to the uh
cookies on melrose grand opening yeah we
were gonna do something man but i don't
think um i don't think he had the
attention to do it we're gonna do
something together we're gonna stony bop
[ __ ] yeah we're gonna do it man it just
never happened just didn't end up
coming to fruition nah but i love elijah
he's a homie
and then uh
you know
you was it michael blanco you did the uh
podcast with and the strain yeah
corleone yeah yeah or michael corleone
not my ass that's my dog but the wii is
called blanco right yeah
yeah so that's
but uh how'd that relationship start
because i listened to that podcast it
was a wild-ass podcast you know um
man one of our team members did a design
with his mom on it and he reached out to
her mutual army he was like
don't get it [ __ ] up by my mother son
dude like you know you're going to do
something to highlight me and i was like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this dude is a boss
called him we just bonded hella right
away we had a lot of things a lot of
mutual friends and just
built a friendship from there just did
some business and that's my guy he's a
he's a man yeah no that was you got to
bring back bernie's roundtable bro i
want to bring him back i'm working on
something right now i'm working on a
deal with it i just my whole thing is it
got to be the right platform they gotta
be right production value
you gotta do video yeah cause a lot the
first one you guys didn't do any video
right yeah there's all audio yeah i
wanna do i wanna do it i'm talking to
someone right now i just told them like
you gotta elevate you gotta complement
the level of business i'm doing right
now i don't wanna just do it for you
know just to do it
is it hard uh
because you you know you hit the road
you do your your yearly shows
is it hard to to for you to step out and
hit that stage with what's going on
right now like as far as just like
getting over that mental blockade that
like [ __ ] there's a thousand people in
front of me i don't know if they got
covered or not
well we just i mean all you can do right
now and yeah no it is [ __ ] scary i
mean all you can do is keep your immune
system strong you know keep your
backstage clean test everyone that's
coming backstage with you and roll the
dice man if i got a show in oklahoma
come up the [ __ ] told me it was
outside it's indoors i'm like god damn
it yeah i mean but it is what it is man
like i get high from the crowd so
what's your uh you you have some crazy
fans uh one in particular i remember was
a guy in tucson arizona had a portrait
of you a fat dude he had a portrait of
you on his [ __ ] belly i love that guy
you know what i'm talking about where's
that guy i sent that guy his roses man
this guy's got a burner portrait on his
belly with the cookies logo underneath
of it like it's tupac thug life yeah and
i was d i was dj in the show and i look
in the crown this guy [ __ ] showed me
i was like
oh this is different you know what's
tight about that [ __ ] bro what's that
about is i know deep down side of you
know god forbid something happens to me
brahma lived for a long time bro like
and i did that off like staying true to
like what i wanted to do like
do cookies through vibes to the music
like i got a place here for a while so
it's tight to see that because that [ __ ]
ain't going nowhere homie's gonna have
that forever he's a grandpa and she's
gonna have that right here
who's that oh this is this guy this is
you know it's a good accomplishment man
like
people got that [ __ ] tattooed all over
the world my logo this night it's a
[ __ ] compliment um you talk about
vibes uh i know you and the guy from raw
papers went at it um for a while
what happened there he's a homie now
dude you and josh worked it out yeah
he's a homie now so why because it was
it was pretty
contentious for a while i literally i
literally kind of stopped following dude
yeah
you know at the end of the day bro
um
i think that just like business is
emotional that that category that
rolling paper category is very small bro
and he's had his he's had his is very
political yeah i think that like
i think he expected me to
just not go do something in that space
and uh
we just recently we started talking
again and i got major i always say in
the interviews too he is the paper don
he's the one that
he he's the boss of the paper game
it doesn't mean that i can't do my thing
too so i think we're in a good position
now to where he respects what i'm doing
and i respect him i always respect him
well you guys had a relationship prior
to you launching vice yeah yeah
yeah he's cool he's a business mogul bro
at the end of the day like i look up to
the kind of business he's accomplished
so it's like i respect him now we had a
falling out and i reacted the way i did
and he reacted the way he did towards me
but i think all that time
went past and let bygones be bygones
it's not like either you guys lost like
respect for each other nah bro i think
he respect i think that i've leveled up
a lot since that falling out and he
respects where i'm at now too has the
paper business been the most challenging
thing you've done because it feels like
a like you said it's a very like
interesting business i'm sure at first
yeah at first it was challenging bro
because there was a lot of roadblocks
you know was it from him or was it from
people other competitors i'm sure it was
but
now we got this in chokehold as a wrap
yeah cause like i see i see it myself
now vibes is like everywhere bro like
we're doing cool products like the cali
like that's innovative as [ __ ] like the
first person to launch like a cylinder
style
you know
product where you could just stuff it
and blaze it it's not a cone and cones
cool the cone don't really hit like that
you know what i mean
so i mean i'm fired up we're doing cool
things like the cubano the cali we got a
lot of things coming out which one is
the red one is that the cali well the
cali the red is a hemp so like okay you
got hemp is red rice is blue and then
black is ultra thin and green is organic
hemp so we have just different skews
what's next man
besides the movies besides the tv is
there anything else
i want to be i want to be a chef bro
you can cook i can cook good so you want
to open a restaurant you want to be a
chef i want to first be a chef it's like
like an ideal world cook for you after
this interview i mean like do some
personal chef [ __ ] and then maybe one
day open a restaurant yeah what is your
um
if you had to open any kind of
restaurant
latin fusion probably latin fusion yeah
i like that so let's say uh i'm like
burn cook me your best dish
i'm coming over for dinner whip some
[ __ ] up what are you making [ __ ]
probably like a like uh
right now my best dish right now is the
lamb chops with the reduced red wine
sauce some nice crispy lemon potatoes
and nice salad on the side
super fire maybe put over some yellow
saffron rice or something like that
is your wife a better cook than you
she has more plates than me she has more
plates yeah which you make you can you
can throw down but she got she's got
more but his team was we both learned to
cook together so yeah
so you getting in the food business is
what's next for the empire probably i
think so yeah hey man i could see it bro
yeah bernie hunter bro i see how dope is
it because you were talking about being
on hate street like freestyle and how
dope is it to have your own [ __ ] on on
that street now life goes bro
do you feel like san francisco because i
now that i'm working with empire i go to
san francisco often at least once a
month i'm there
and you know i'll talk to guys like uh
like amen or you know shabazz like guys
from the bay and they're like yo the
energy's kind of out of the city right
now it is
like what like what do you think kind of
the bay is right now because
i'll go there and i'll be like man i
remember when i was coming here five or
six years ago like there was like a
it feels like the vibe is kind of
missing right now
the bay area is a tough place
that's the best way i could describe it
it's just tough
every aspect of life just tough it's
expensive
expensive
a lot of not a lot of people made it
from the bay people don't trust each
other there's no unity like it's just
weird yeah it feels like a very like uh
especially now too like
you can't even go to a [ __ ]
restaurant if you're not vaccinated it's
just you can't even go to a restaurant
without getting your windows broken
either so it's like you know oh yeah
cause it's it's the smash and grab
capital that's why i'm doing the movies
splash city it's crazy
new school ninja as you drive baby is
that what the movie's kind of yeah it's
all based on that
yeah cause for people who don't know san
francisco's the smash and grab capital
of the world
it's crazy your window gets smashed out
if you've got anything in your [ __ ]
car and if you don't there's gonna pop
in windows they're just gonna see what's
in there yeah that [ __ ] is wild man
yeah
that [ __ ] is crazy so the new album that
you're working on right now is it going
to be coming out before the end of the
year
yeah
what's it called do we know i'm working
on that name right now it's very the
name is very
it's going to take some
i have to get some permission for the
name but just know it's going to be
mafia i'll just leave it at that mafia
[ __ ] mafia
is it
some movie [ __ ]
nah but it's tight bro trust me it's
next level dude
it's gonna be sick i'll tell you offline
like you always are so good at your
artwork too
this one's gonna be [ __ ] crazy yeah i
feel like you've had the same dude doing
your covers from the jump photo doctor
kills it he's best yeah yeah it's it's
like uh
everything's consistent except for i
want to say the one where you had the
guy do the weed was that yeah
yeah yeah uh
big piscata yeah yeah i know it was that
yeah yeah
it's so crazy how you don't even know
because you have like 50 million
albums i have no [ __ ] clue anymore
well listen man uh i can't wait to hear
the new music right on brother
appreciate you having me man of course
bro when you hit me i was like we gotta
do it for sure yeah um
go go get you some cookies
yeah man go go get your lungs right man
get your lungs right get your gear right
smoke some vibes is zoomy's the biggest
like retailer that holds cookies right
now
um
probably the biggest chain store yeah
it's so crazy man i just i got [ __ ]
the new [ __ ] yard dropping luggage
[ __ ] i got it's not gonna stop i
bought the cookie slides my puppy [ __ ]
them up shout out to my new french
bulldog [ __ ] up my red ones
don't worry i've got another box coming
for you yeah yeah listen man i
appreciate you burn brother and um i am
proud of you bro i don't man i'm gonna
do what i do i'm gonna go get to work
man let's go
burner blue light cat podcast boom